so six years old and this is a korean
family spa so there's children there all
the time
this is the children's section at wii
spa they have like a whole little
playroom
and so this is her in a little playroom
like i said it's a korean spa
so um everyone's naked and
i you know i wanted to be kind of
culturally with it so
we also were nude in the women's
side of the spa and the women's section
has like hot tubs
and like massage areas and everyone's
nude
so we got into the hot tub my little
six-year-old daughter and i
and we're having a great time we're in
there with other women when a person
i guess with a penis and a beard came
over
with two uh girlfriends and they sat
down on the edge of the hot tub where i
was with my daughter my six-year-old
daughter who was naked
and the person with sat down on the edge
of the hot tub
with uh just fully on display with his
genitals fully on display
and so me and the other women in the hot
sub kind of
looked each other in the eye and we just
kind of made this face like what the
heck
and uh you know we're motioning to my
daughter i'm motioning to my daughter
and the women in the hot tub are like i
know what the hell
and um you know we were just
uncomfortable and i was trying to block
my daughter from seeing the
on the person with the five o'clock
shadow who was not trying to look like a
woman at all
and we got a hot tub and i walked away
and i thought it spoke to like a
different woman
and a woman this other woman said um you
know they spoke to
this person about covering up but they
refused and i
felt kind of horrified um i could see
like the older korean ladies
peeking out from behind the the kind of
panels of the showers
trying to cover themselves up with a
towel um all the women were
uncomfortable
no one wanted to say anything everyone
in la is pretty progressive
i'm a registered democrat i've been to
gay pride i have no problem with gay
people no problem trans people
this is different this is different
my daughter's six years old and she was
like
nude and this person wasn't making any
attempts to look like a woman whatsoever
they walked in with the most entitled
attitude
almost like spreading their legs on
purpose into a korean
it's really really really korean too
they didn't care about making the old
korean ladies uncomfortable
they just walked in almost hoping
someone would say something
so i was uncomfortable i left with my
daughter and
went downstairs to talk to someone at
the front desk and they apologized
and i got these two free passes to a spa
because i was upset so that's what they
gave me and they said sorry
yeah i'm sorry you felt upset about what
you saw in the spa
but here two free passes so you can see
again twice
you know that's like it's like
it's like being too uh being given two
defective copies of cyberpunk
and then when you complain they give you
two more we'll go
hey if you didn't like our buddy game
the first time how about the second time
sorry here's a rebate for next time
you're gonna buy it
and then i spent the next day just
really feeling
horrible it took me the whole day to
even tell my husband what happened i
didn't want to say what happened i
couldn't really talk about it without
crying
i don't like i said i've not i've been
to pride on santa monica many times it's
fun i
have friends where i used to no this
isn't
about that and i hate she's like she's
wearing no i have
why am i just define myself the same
about that no that's what happened in
the brain i feel
and i understand it all right preach
all right the blood of jesus it's
happening people
people are getting fed up this next
generation because of the generation
that we are now the next generation are
going to be fascists
they're going to balance that [ __ ] out
the kids kids right now
are actually sick and tired of hearing
this they're
not complying with this this
vague way of seeing gender and stuff
like that they're not doing this
but whatever it's just i appreciate the
fact that she said a person with a beard
she's like being very neutral which is
fine at the end of the day that's what
it is a person with a beard
but hey the problem lady was that
your six-year-old daughter was not
educated
about grown man
you gotta educate her i guess
what do you tell a parent who's worried
about this kind of stuff
you know we we covered a lot of the
logistics in the last video we did on
this topic where
we talked about the nuance of it so i
don't want to go back to that if you
guys want to hear our thoughts on
why it's stuff for trans folks and all
that stuff go to that video okay
all right there'll be a link in the
description you can find it there this
person was purposefully flashing them
sat on the edge of the tub saw they were
uncomfortable had their legs open like
that
listen maybe they're not even trains
okay
i don't know who knows right maybe
there's someone who's trolling
what i am trying to say is because of
this rule there are people like this
will come out
it's inevitable it's inevitable you give
people a current blush to go do whatever
they want
they will do it i promise you if there's
a loophole
people are going to loop even if it's
not legal
people will do weird stuff so now that
it is
bruh it's dead and after question i
don't think these people had an issue
with a trans person being there
they're saying if you have that anatomy
you just flaunt again the space that's
supposed to be safe for women does not
make them feel safe
and i can understand that the same way a
woman
or an individual having female body
parts
walking into a male space probably
wouldn't feel safe
based off of the other kid into the room
it's it's kind of simple to me
and you know i think in all this you
know bsi it's like
to me it's just the idea like i don't
know how this is not a big deal
especially how we are around kids the
movie cuties came out everyone lost
their minds
and to me that is nothing
compared to this is it smartsie no
did i tell any lies no real thing so
i'm just like how do i get so outraged
for a movie that's trying to didn't cur
like not encourage that but when this is
happening
y'all don't say [ __ ] yes i was walking
on
and i saw a girl with a shirt on and it
says the future is female
and i was like
it's not
it's not not according to all the same
spacey people
what do you mean what creature is female
i'm like listen what do you mean
no no why would it be it's not
uh man the problem is man no
it's a woman so
eve we can't move
we can't lose do you understand a lot of
ladies were messaging me
after the last video yes you know i'm
too terrified to speak up
i appreciate you speaking on our behalf
this is your face this is you
this is you this is you this is you this
is you all right not us not us nope not
the hit tv show
no no no no no this is you this is you
all right so y'all got to go and speak
up on us
but what we're seriously going to have i
have a discussion but we can't because
having a discussion
is being phobic so
look like we're stuck in our butt yeah
yeah yeah
good to let it go we're gonna have to
have a discussion right here i don't
even know why i was fighting this the
whole time
it's not my fight it's not your fight
yeah it's not a f
it's not our fight yeah i don't see
ladies getting out for men's rights you
know why it's not her fight no i don't
see
i don't see you know why it's not her
fight good because we were never part of
the discussion in the first place
no the reason why it's not a fight is
because the future is female
it's not exactly so you know what i wish
you guys the best of luck
hopefully you guys work it out and you
reclaim your bathrooms and your change
rooms uh otherwise
hey man i realize i got no skin in the
game so
best of luck to all your daughters i got
no first kill in the game
[Music]
play
no time for fake ones
[Music]
for me